[Music]
now that wagering is legal in plenty of
american states you can bet on who will
win the division caesar's palace has put
out the odds for
the division champions and and the one
just i hope for the poor dolphins the
afc east and it makes sense the patriots
have won the division every year
since 2003 with the exception of 2008
they've won it 10 years in a row they
are minus 850 favorites that means you
have to bet 850 dollars to win a hundred
dollars that is what it would take if
you pick the patriots at the other end
of the spectrum below the the jets at
plus 650 and the bill's at plus 1000 you
have the dolphins at plus 10 000. you
put down 100 bucks on the dolphins they
win the division you get 10 000 bucks
even then chris i would not be inclined
to to waste my hundred dollars it would
have to maybe be a hundred plus a
hundred thousand before i would put a
hundred dollars down if i was inclined
to do that and i'm not anyway on the
miami dolphins no no i'm definitely not
wasting my money there certainly not i
mean it's a it's a total rebuild with
miami right now i mean yeah there was
issues on that roster and that's what
we're seeing i mean ryan fitzpatrick's
are starting quarterback right now if
that doesn't tell you you know rebuild
or you know
year transition whatever however you
want to phrase it certainly i mean i
think it is awesome that we're seeing
the cleveland browns on top of the afc
north are you kidding me when's the last
time they've been on top of the afc
north and the graphic like that as far
as division leaders the the bet money on
i mean i haven't seen them in front of
pittsburgh uh or baltimore since i i
don't even know when i mean what is it
late 90s is it the 80s does it go that
far back but it's just really cool to
see their name up there i i certainly do
like that
yeah i don't think the browns have been
a favorite to win the afc north since
it's been the afc north that's the only
year they made the playoffs the first
year of the afc north it was the afc
central and it was the days of bernie
cosar i think oh no it was kelsey
well they had that one year where they
had kelly holcomb and they were in 2002
right exactly right they they they were
a wild card team first year of the afc
north four team division you know for a
while they had six teams in that
division and it was usually the browns
and the bengals finishing fifth or sixth
respectively but they made the playoffs
in 2002 lost to the steelers in the wild
card round that's the only time they
made the postseason since the browns
returned to the nfl in 99 they are plus
150 they have the best odds in the afc
north the steelers at plus 180 and look
all this talk about the brown it's just
going to make the steelers quietly
determined nothing is going to focus the
steelers on the task at hand and getting
past all of the ugliness from the 2018
season and le'veon bell and antonio
brown and all the dysfunction in the
drama then having themselves looking up
at the browns this is actually a good
development for the steelers my
experience living in and around
pittsburgh most of my life when the bar
is high for the steelers they fail to
reach it when the bar is low they have a
very good season and i think this is all
setting up for the steelers to quietly
surprise a lot of teams and to keep the
browns from ascending to the top of the
division they're going to remind
everyone there's still a team in
pittsburgh that's pretty good and those
games between the browns and the
steelers this year could end up being
pretty great yeah no no question about
it i mean the afc north in general i
mean and and to your point with
pittsburgh yes not only are they looking
up at the cleveland browns i think a lot
of people look at the baltimore ravens
and probably put them on an equal
playing field with pittsburgh steelers
so they don't have the bullseye on their
back this year they are part of you know
the hunting group in general but uh yes
pittsburgh the big thing with them is
just how do they handle all this
offseason turmoil you know big ben and
people taking shots of his reputation
and his leadership and all of those
things i would think they do handle it
uh well i i think that they're gonna be
happy that bell and brown are all out
and those distractions are gone but the
afc north has quickly become the most
one of the most intriguing divisions in
all of football and hey mike i look at
the afc south and you go colts with the
jaguars and nick foles now with the
quarterback situation and the texans uh
of course those three teams i think
they're all
super bowl contenders and mike i'll ask
you this with kansas city up there at
minus 250 if tyree kill gets in trouble
here and gets suspended how far does
that drop the minus 250 does it go back
to an eagle equal playing field do they
go back to the positives i mean that he
is that kind of a game changer where uh
i would think it certainly sways the
odds big time
yeah right now it's chiefs minus 250
chargers plus 325 raiders plus 900
broncos plus 1200 in the afc west and
look what's happening the chiefs is last
week their starting center mitch moore
signs with the bills demetrius harris
blocking tight end key part of the
offense signs with the browns chris
connolly quiet transaction we haven't
mentioned yet over the weekend signs of
the jaguars he was on the receiving end
of some of the best touchdown passes
that patrick mahomes threw last year and
he instinctively understood what it
means to be a receiver for patrick
mahomes he's gone so if tyree kill would
end up being gone from the chiefs this
year i'll tell you what you better do
you better make a trade you better make
a trade for antonio brown or roto
beckham jr pretty quickly although it
may be hard to do that since they were
just traded one thing that really jumped
out at me two things first of all first
of all
these odds come from caesar's palace
right and a year ago we probably
wouldn't have even been talking about
this now
caesar's palace is the official casino
partner of the national football league
it is amazing how the world has changed
in just one year but these are the
official odds from the official casino
partner of the national football league
and one thing here's my other point one
thing that really stood out to me
looking for the one that i would put my
money on if i were to wager which i
don't and i it's like boy you say that
so much you probably do i don't
look at the nfc south chris look at it
right now there's one team in the nfc
south that is screaming screaming
bet on me i want i want you to tell me
which team you think that is well i mean
all those teams are good i mean i'm not
going to bet anything these are to win
the super bowl right or to win the
division oh these are to win the
division
the bucks are the bucks are screaming
then the bucks are screaming the
panthers wrong wrong and
oh okay sorry
the pan look at but look at it cam
newton's shoulder gets fixed the
panthers were great last year until cam
couldn't throw the ball down the field
you take the ability of a quarterback to
throw down the ball down the field off
the table the team is going to fall
apart if newton's healthy that plus 700
is a steal because the saints at minus
two i'm sorry folks i know the saints
covered great adversity minneapolis
miracle they made it back to the
championship game i think the saints are
going to start moving in the other
direction max unger retired i think drew
brees may have father time breathing
down his neck i just don't
mark ingram's gone latavius murray i'm
sorry has no mark ingram i think the
saints are going to take a step back and
at the panthers i now look the falcons
at plus 350 maybe they could be the ones
yeah but i think plus 700 is a smart bet
on the panthers i think the panthers are
going to win that division yeah it's a
little steep certainly it jumped out to
me i mean the falcons at plus 350 jumped
out to me and i don't think the the
bucks are not going to be uh any cupcake
either this year i mean that's a sneaky
good roster that's why bruce ahrens took
over that job uh so i think they're a
team that could be very relevant in this
conversation as well which all those
three teams will love the new orleans
saints with them being improved and
better and cam newton's shoulder being
fixed yes i don't think the road will be
as easy for the new orleans saints just
to get out of the nfc south this year
and i am a little worried too after two
huge you know defeating losses in the
playoffs two years in a row you got some
injuries to guys like sheldon rankin's
got some other issues on the defensive
line with guys that might not be able to
play offensive lineman like you said
with max
unger that's a huge blow to that
football team so yeah the saints i'm
certainly not as high on them
as i was going into last year or the
year before
how do you reset to zero and zero two
years in a row after having your heart
ripped out the first time around you
could just say the football gods put it
to you the second time around it felt
like the league put it to you and all
that that consternation and the acrimony
i just think it you throw everything in
the same pot plus the fact that drew
brees seems to be unless he's secretly
injured and i love drew brees he's a
first battle hall of famer one of the
great quarterbacks of all time made the
argument last year he could be in the
top five by the time it's all said and
done there's reason to believe that he's
starting to decline and if that's the
case the saints are gonna have a hard
time repeating as the nfc south
champions all right chris how about your
new york football giants plus 1500
bringing up the rear and behind
washington for crying out loud what's
the world coming to the dysfunctional
washington nfl franchise and the giants
are regarded as even more dysfunctional
well hey i mean you look at washington
you go okay let's evaluate the rosters
right now i mean washington's offensive
line better than the giants quarterback
position at washington better than the
giants okay the giants i don't think
anybody knows what they're doing right
now safety position oh they just got the
giant safety better than the giants i
mean yes the new york giants right now
uh you know it's just it's hard to
figure out exactly what direction
they're going in or they're in the
process of changing their team and their
approach of how they play and i think
that's why you saw them sign a golden
tate last week it's no hey they realize
i think they've realized we're going all
in on eli manning they gave him his five
million dollar bonus okay they went okay
no more odell beckham jr there's no
point in having him because eli is not
going to stand in there and throw the
ball deep so they're gonna run the
football that's why they traded for a
kevin zeitler who's still a really good
guard with the you know from the
cleveland browns but they're gonna run
it they're gonna play play-action passes
down the middle to evan ingram sterling
shepard short passes to golden state i
mean golden tate and that's how they're
going to play football this year uh and
i'm interested to see if it really will
work i know saquon will work i'm not
sure about the pass game we'll see
you weren't here on friday so we didn't
really have a chance to talk about it
but and look i understand what the
giants are trying to do but the idea
that golden tate is the replacement for
obj and and golden tate is very good at
what he does but they are in two
different categories and it just it just
it just fueled
the perception among giants fans that
the giants just don't know what the heck
they're doing and and you know it very
well may be that you know if eli manning
can't get the ball to odell beckham it's
not worth having him around but still
golden tate and they gave golden tate a
nice contract yes they did golden tate
is not going to come close to replacing
odo beckham jr no there's no not even
the same stratosphere he won't even be
asked to do the same things golden tate
is more along the lines of a slot
receiver who's going to work underneath
coverage catch bubble screens wide
receiver screens out on the edge do that
type of thing uh hey listen i was a big
fan when the eagles traded for golden
tate last year i thought that would
really help their offense but you know
evaluating golden tickets
but it didn't because
because evaluating golden tate he has
lost a step there's no denying that and
i think that's why you didn't see
philadelphia get in the market or try to
uh re-sign him because they realized
that after evaluating not only in games
and in practice that he just doesn't
have the same juice in his legs that he
used to
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports